I don't think it is going to happen
because the key person who was really
holding alongside the last band of
interests of investors is a man called
Trevor Hemmings who's a billionaire from
the northwest of England and he has
accepted or last night
he accepted the offer that Ross McEwan
made of 82 pence per share so
unfortunately because he has now
accepted that settlement offer they need
and that they would need an additional
seven million pounds of funding to be
able to proceed with the case and in his
absence they have no way of finding that
so despite the fact that many of these
individual investors would wish to
pursue the case as far as I'm aware the
yet the fact that that trevor Hemmings
has chosen to settle has made it
impossible for the case to proceed you
rather keen that there isn't a
settlement in order that we get a public
hearing of this case I think it would
have been preferable to have had a trial
because we would have we would have
found out more about the shenanigans
that went on inside RBS in the build-up
to the rights issue announcement of 22nd
of April 2008 and the decision-making
that went on I mean it's almost certain
that the were things that were cut that
were covered up or not fully disclosed
including the the funding from the
Federal Reserve which was about 11 to 12
billion u.s. dollars which was a
clandestine emergency funding package
from the Fed and things like that the
fact that Hector Sands who was the then
chief executive of the Financial
Services Authority actually ordered the
rights issue and that wasn't disclosed
in the prospectus yes a bank settled
with most other groups of shareholders
who are these shareholders that have
been holding out until now there's about
eighteen thousand nine hundred
individual investors and who are left in
the you know who were the last to settle
and this group of investors are all
individuals yeah they're almost entirely
individuals but there's one or two small
institutions once they've settled in
December were big groups like
Standard Life Investments MMG Prudential
people like that so so really that the
ones that settled earlier on for a lower
sum were the large institutions and the
ones that settled at the very end for
for a slightly higher some are mainly
individuals assuming we don't get a
court case here assuming we do get some
out-of-court settlement is there a case
in your opinion for there being some
sort of public inquiry into this given
the amount of public money that has gone
on RBS over the last decade I I think
it's getting you know with every passing
year it gets more and more difficult to
do something I do think that the FSA
report which was published in December
2011 well was a bit of a damp squib
you know they've basically found that
all the the board of RBS had done was
make a few mistakes and they also found
that there had been no corporate
governance failures at RBS and you know
basically exonerated the board of the
bank now for a bank which actually
became the most expensive bank in the
world to bail out and which has still
failed to return to profitability nine
years after its collapse
one does wonder whether that FSA report
was was was that was actually accurate
but a public inquiry I I personally
would welcome it because I think it's
important these matters are brought out
into the public domain it's one of the
reasons why I'm disappointed that
doesn't appear that the case is actually
going to go ahead